[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend in einen das asaf
stahlwerk im südosten der ukraine muss
die dort seit wochen eingeschlossenen
menschen die hölle auf erden sein es ist
auch zu einem symbol geworden die letzte
bastion ukrainischer kämpfer in der von
russland fast komplett eroberten und
fast komplett zerstörten stadt mariupol
jetzt haben russische einheiten mit
einer großoffensive begonnen die nicht
nur dem stahlwerk gilt sie soll den
besatzern auch eine landverbindung zur
krim sichern york bill hat mehr
raketen auf die letzte bastion des
ukrainischen widerstand in mariupol das
off stahlwerk die erstürmung durch die
russische armee soll begonnen haben noch
immer befinden sich im inneren wohl auch
zivilisten
es war kurz nach zwei in der nacht
plötzlich eine entsetzliche explosion es
gab ein dutzend verletzte gebrochene
beine arme und dann diese beiden mädchen
was müssen sie gelitten haben sie
wollten doch nur weg von hier die
ganze nacht über sei das oft stahlwerk
bombardiert worden derzeit läuft ein
groß angelegter angriff auf den
industriekomplex des konzerns als stahl
mit unterstützung von bodentruppen
panzern und schiffen vom wasser aus wir
werden alles tun um diesen angriff
abzuwehren
wie es im rest der belagerten stadt
aussieht zeigen diese aufnahmen über
100.000 zivilisten harren derzeit
offenbar noch in mario pohl aus eine von
ihnen ist tatjana buschland over
du wachst morgens auf und weinst du
weinst am abend ich weiß nicht wo ich
hingehen soll und damit bin ich nicht
alleine alles ist zerstört alles ist
kaputt wo sollen wir hin gehen und
während sie dort inmitten von trümmern
sitzt und erzählt schlägt ganz in ihrer
nähe wieder eine rakete
sie sind der hölle von mario pohl
entkommen haben es aus dem es oft
stahlwerk heraus geschafft endlich mit
bussen kommen sie heute in sapporo an
ihr versteht nicht wie schrecklich es
ist wenn du in einem nassen kalten
keller sitzt und es rüttelt und wackelt
überall als wir endlich auf die straße
raus gehen konnten sah ich die sonne zum
zweiten mal in zwei monaten
es ist tag 69 des krieges und die
menschen wollen nur noch weg egal wie
die sonne zum zweiten mal in zwei
monaten das ist die lage in der kiew
heute einen besucher aus deutschland
empfängt der damit zu hause schlagzeilen
macht und eine ziemliche diskussion
ausgelöst hat deutschland dürfte das
einzige land sein aus dem der
oppositionschef die ukraine im krieg
noch vor dem regierungschef besucht
jetzt kann man sagen das ist egal wer
wann kommt man kann auch sagen das ist
ein politikum ich habe gleich fragen an
friedrich merz aber erst mathis feldhoff
über einen oppositionsführer auf der
suche nach eigenen eindrücken vor ort
und auf der suche nach seiner rolle im
krieg
wenn der deutsche oppositionsführer bei
einer reise nicht nur den kiefer
bürgermeister vitali klitschko und sein
bruder trifft sondern hinter
verschlossenen türen auch den
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky
spricht das für zwei lesarten wie
deutsche unterstützung wird geschätzt
und deutsche politiker werden im prinzip
gern empfangen in diese vision unserer
zeit
besucher zu haben freunde
so sehr ist sehr wichtig dass es eine
symbolische besuch wir schützen und
verteidigen ja auch unsere demokratie
unsere freiheit so wie wir leben auch in
deutschland am vormittag war märz
zunächst in ihr team
vor ort von kiew hier so erzählt es ihm
der bürgermeister waren die kämpfer am
heftigsten hier wurde der russische
vormarsch auf die hauptstadt gestört
friedrich merz ist sichtlich ergriffen
nach einem blick in eines der zerstörten
häuser
das ist so furchtbar sagt der cdu
vorsitzende mehr zu sich selbst nichts
ist mehr in ihre bienen die von 69 tagen
vor dem kriegsbeginn
ich bin voller trauer über die
zahlreichen opfer dies hier gegeben hat
aber auch gleichzeitig voller
bewunderung über das was die armee was
die ukrainischen soldatinnen und
soldaten hier geleistet haben märz folgt
bei seiner reise einer einfachen
strategie er treibt die bundesregierung
schon bei den waffenlieferungen so
findet er habe das funktioniert heute
sichert in berlin durch das die
koalition jetzt auch bereits schwere
panzer und witzen zu liefern für märz
ist das eine gratwanderung einerseits
oppositionsführer andererseits
unterstützer der regierung in
kriegszeiten noch vor ein paar tagen
voller attacke auf den abwesenden
kanzler der bundeskanzler hat über
wochen die diskussion über die frage ob
der ukraine der nun waffen geliefert
werden sollten oder nicht hingehalten
offengelassen ausweichend beantwortete
olaf scholz versucht den spieß
umzudrehen merz reise sein wahrheit eine
mission im auftrag der regierung so die
subtile botschaft des kanzlers erstens
hat er mich aber seinen wunsch
informiert und ich habe da keine
anwendung und sie billige das und
zweitens ist es so dass wir natürlich
auch hinterher über das was er mir
mitzuteilen hat sprechen werden es ist
eine wunde in der koalition dass die
reisetätigkeit der regierung so
gehandicapt ist dem vizekanzler ist
seine unzufriedenheit förmlich
anzumerken
der opposition nicht auch in die ukraine
gereist dass wir als wir noch nicht da
sind das hat ja der bundeskanzler
ausgeführt liegt im kern auch daran dass
der bundespräsident ausgeladen wurde und
da wird es aber auch eine lösung geben
ihre rinder dauern miteinander ein
machtkampf zwischen ihm und dem kanzler
fast generis kündigt merz heute an er
wolle jetzt auch helfen die gründe für
scholz reise und lust nach kiew
auszuräumen
friedrich merz cdu chef und
oppositionsführer im deutschen bundestag
ist jetzt bei uns in der sendung aus
kiew guten abend herr merz
der sievers was hat sie denn persönlich
am meisten mitgenommen an diesem tag
heute in kiew
das war eindeutig der besucher im
stadtteil alpinen also in dem stadtteil
der wie butter auch massiv zerstört
worden ist kirchen kulturzentren
kindergärten krankenhäuser private
wohnung völlig sinnlose zerstörung und
dann die menschen getroffen die in
diesen häusern gewohnt haben den
bürgermeister getroffen der dort
gleichzeitig auch der militärkommandant
war als der russische angriff auf die
stadt kiew begonnen hat also das muss
man mal aus der nähe gesehen haben um
den eindruck wirklich zu bekommen wie
schrecklich dieser krieg ist und wie
völlig sinnlos diese zerstörungen sind
die hier auch tatsächlich angerichtet
worden sind das muss man mal aus der
nähe gesehen haben haben sie gerade
gesagt ist das ein wink mit dem
zaunpfahl auch an den bundeskanzler
also das muss er selber entscheiden ich
kann es ihm nur empfehlen das zu tun
auch die gespräche dann hier zu führen
ich habe heute den staatspräsidenten
getroffen den ministerpräsidenten
getroffen den parlamentspräsidenten
getroffen die oppositionsführer
getroffen und dann zum schluss noch
vladimir klitschko als bürgermeister der
stadt kiew diese gespräche können sie
nicht am telefon machen die können sie
auch nicht mit videokonferenzen machen
sie müssen diese gespräche persönlich
führen und das ist schon eindrucksvoll
was dieses land auch was die politische
führung dieses landes hier leistet und
ich kann es jedem nur empfehlen diese
gespräche zu führen ich bin jedenfalls
zutiefst dankbar dass ich heute diesen
tag hier verbringen konnte jetzt ist es
aber herr merz so dass der bundeskanzler
ja tatsächlich
oft ständig regelmäßig und lange mit
präsident zielinski eben telefoniert was
können sie denn den bundeskanzler jetzt
noch über bringen was er nicht ohnehin
schon weiß
sie was ich würde ganz gerne das was ich
ihm zu sagen habe auch aus meinen
persönlichen gesprächen die ihr
persönlich auch übermitteln und das
nicht über die nachrichten tun aber ich
kann durchaus einiges sagen auch zu den
zukünftigen beziehungen mit der ukraine
zu dem was wir tun könnten auch jenseits
der waffenlieferungen da geht es ja auch
um die fragen des wiederaufbaus da geht
es um die fragen auch der nato der der
europäischen union und der
mitgliedschaft in der europäischen union
da geht es um die frage auch der
garantie mächte für die zukunft also da
gibt es einige politische fragen aber
die würde ich gerne mit ihm persönlich
klären nicht über die medien und sie
meinen das ist etwas was präsident sie
lenski nicht direkt mit olaf scholz auch
am telefon besprechen könnte wozu er
dann friedrich merz quasi als boten
braucht
nein sie war es nochmal ich mache doch
meine reise nicht unter dem aspekt was
kann ich an botschaft mit nach hause
bringen und was kann nicht der
bundesregierung sagen das ist da wenn
ich meine aufgabe meine aufgabe ist mir
ein persönliches bild zu machen von der
lage auch ein persönliches bild in den
gesprächen mit den repräsentanten dieses
landes und das habe ich heute getan ich
bin ja auch nicht alleine hier ich habe
meinen bundestagskollegen oder recht
diese wird mit dabei gehabt und wir
haben diese gespräche hier sehr intensiv
geführt und eines kann ich ganz gewiss
sagen die persönlichen gespräche sind
durch nichts zu ersetzen durch kein
telefon durch keine video codecs und
auch die dankbarkeit mal entgegen zu
nehmen für das was wir auch in der
letzten woche im deutschen bundestag auf
unsere initiative hin geschlossen haben
das ist schon eine bestätigung dessen
dass wir da nicht ganz falsch gelegen
haben was wir dann gemeinsam in bonn im
berliner bundestag besprochen haben also
das ist durch nichts zu ersetzen was
dann an persönlichen gesprächen die auch
stattfindet jetzt haben sich ihre
gesprächspartner in der ukraine heute
gewundert dass erst der deutsche
oppositionschef kommt und dann erst
möglicherweise der deutsche
regierungschef
ja das kann man so sagen also ich habe
hier auch im übrigen einen
medienaufgebot gefunden mit dem ich
weder gerechnet habe noch das ich
erwartet habe oder ausgelöst habe das
zeigt mir aber wie groß das bedürfnis
nach solchen persönlichen gesprächen ist
und deswegen kann ich es nur empfehlen
zu tun ich habe lange drauf gewartet die
bundesregierung hat es bis jetzt nicht
für richtig befunden es zu tun das ist
ihre entscheidung aber davon mache ich
dann meine entscheidung nicht abhängig
auch ein solches gespräch und eine
solche reise zu unternehmen
und ja die aufmerksamkeit war sehr groß
übrigens bis hin in die details der
abstimmung in der letzten woche die wir
im deutschen bundestag am 9 am
donnerstag hatten das wussten meine
gesprächspartner alle und zwar bis auf
das abstimmungsergebnis dass wir dann
dort auch gehabt haben was haben sie
denn dem ukrainischen präsidenten gesagt
dazu dass er den deutschen
bundespräsidenten ausgeladen hatte der
bundeskanzler sieht ja exakt das als
größtes hindernis für seine eigene reise
also wir haben darüber gesprochen aber
auch da bitte ich um verständnis dass
ich das jetzt hier im detail nicht
wiedergebe bevor ich das nicht dem
bundeskanzler gesagt habe ich will nur
vielleicht eines ganz grundsätzlich
sagen ich finde dass der sprachgebrauch
auf beiden seiten so sein sollte dass
wir uns die zusammenarbeit nicht unnötig
schwer machen wir müssen uns doch jetzt
hier nicht gegenseitig auch öffentlich
kritisieren sondern hier geht es um ein
land im krieg ein land das angegriffen
worden ist und dem wir nach allen
kräften die wir haben helfen wollen und
das muss das gemeinsame ziel sein und
das sollte auch jenseits aller rhetorik
das ziel sein an dem wir unabhängig
davon welche rolle wir einnehmen ob
regierung oder opposition an dem ziel
müssen wir gemeinsam arbeiten jetzt ist
die konstellation haben wir doch schon
ein bisschen ungewöhnlich auch
verglichen mit anderen europäischen
ländern
wir sprechen gerade mit ihnen als
oppositionschef in kiew sie herr merz
haben natürlich nicht so sehr viel
mitbringen können an konkreten zusagen
als oppositionspolitiker verglichen mit
der regierung umgekehrt können sie das
haben sie auch schon getan natürlich
jetzt immer sagen seht her ich war da
der bundeskanzler nicht was hat diese
reise für ihren landtagswahlkampf in dem
sie ja auch gerade stecken gebracht
er sie was ich glaube was wir beide
müssen uns mal ganz grundsätzlich
darüber verständigen ob
oppositionsführer überhaupt reisen
dürfen oder nicht und welchen sinn
solche reisen haben ich habe doch als
oppositionsführer nicht nur dann einen
reiseanlass wenn ich etwas mitzubringen
habe ich nehme mir das recht den
anspruch jedes land dieser welt aus
eigenem anschauen heraus anzusehen und
reisen zu machen so wie ich sie für
notwendig und für richtig halte auch um
politische gespräche zu führen und das
geht doch nicht darum dass sich jeweils
in die eine oder die andere richtung was
mitbringen also da kommt doch so ein
unterton rein als oppositionsführer
nicht reisen dürfen ich mache die reisen
und zwar die die ich für richtig halte
er sie was und heute nach kiew das war
der oppositionsführer im deutschen
bundestag friedrich merz ich danke ihnen
ganz herzlich für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen und
das gespräch aber aus termingründen vor
zweieinhalb stunden aufgezeichnet
seit jeher gehört zur agenda sämtlicher
despoten und diktatoren als erstes mal
die freiheit der presse abzuschaffen
damit niemand mehr unbequeme fragen
gestellt damit niemand mehr erfährt was
geschieht damit die vielstimmigkeit der
demokratie zum schweigen gebracht wird
demokratie da es in darkness ist der
wahlspruch der washington post und er
gilt nicht nur heute am welttag der
pressefreiheit
es sieht nicht gut aus auf der neuen
rangliste der organisation reporter ohne
grenzen deutschland verschlechtert sich
dort um drei plätze
griechenland um 38 steht jetzt auf rang
108 in der welt weit hinter bulgarien
und ungarn
und dann der krieg gegen die ukraine
einen krieg den die russische führung
auch gegen alle führt die über sie
kritisch berichten wollen und der arm
des kreml reicht bis nach berlin
stefanie dosch das russische haus in
berlin nur kulturinstitut angeblich von
ihr sendete radio russkij oder auch
koloss berliner dies archivaufnahmen
ein deutscher radiosender in russischer
sprache
seit sonntag sind die räume leer die
mikros abgebaut moskau gefiel wohl nicht
dass sie kritische bedingt krieg in der
ukraine berichteten also mussten sie
raus und sollten bis dahin schweigen man
hat uns gesagt es wäre schön wenn wir
bis zum auszug bis zum ersten mal
keine nachrichten und keine politischen
programme senden und nur musik spielen
ich sehe das wirklich auch als ein
eingriff in die pressefreiheit und zwar
ganz eindeutig wir fragen schriftlich
beim russischen haus nach sie antworten
nicht doch auf dem account der
russischen häuser bei telegramm etwas
das wirkt wie propaganda die haltung
klar
zitat
es gibt nazis muss in der ukraine
russland beschützt diejenigen die seit
acht jahren genozid seitens der
regierung in kiew erleiden müssen
krieg um worte und bilder selten ist die
arbeit von journalistinnen und
journalisten so bedeutend wie in
militärischen konflikten und auch so
gefährlich
mindestens sieben starben in der ukraine
bereits
dieter krieg zeigt einmal mehr wie
wichtig pressefreiheit ist wie wichtig
unabhängige informationen sind und
gleichzeitig weil dieser konflikt ja die
ganze welt öffentlichkeit berührt und
mehr berührt als andere konflikte zeigt
es auch die bedeutung und auch die
gefährdung für pressefreiheit radio
golos berliner damit weiter ein
medienhaus hat sie vorübergehend
aufgenommen zudem geben sie nun ihm eine
stimme andreas koch moderierte beim
unabhängigen radiosender echo moskau mit
beginn des krieges wurde dieser verboten
er flog meinungsfreiheit passt nicht in
putins krieg
vorher war es so dass wenn putin
beschuldigt wurde dass er die
meinungsfreiheit in russland zerstört
dann konnte er bequem sagen warum haben
wir die meinungsfreiheit zu stören wir
haben doch den radiosender echo moskau
den unabhängigen fernsehsender dort und
die zeitung nowaja gaseta
nun in kriegszeiten sind die dinge sehr
viel strikter und er kann es sich nicht
mehr leisten die geringste
meinungsfreiheit zuzulassen
zu berichten die zwei nun gemeinsam aus
berlin auf russisch kritisch über den
krieg in der ukraine putin kann das
nicht verhindern
russland steht bei reporter ohne grenzen
auf rang 155 von 180 im eigenen land
habe russland nach dem überfall auf die
ukraine die pressefreiheit de facto
abgeschafft
auf die spur des russischen präsidenten
seiner versteckten willen und reichtümer
hat sich einer gemacht der dafür bitter
bezahlen musste der dem tod knapp
entgangen ist und jetzt in einem
straflager sitzt
solange wladimir putin an der macht ist
dürfte alexej nawalny kein freier mann
mehr werden und gleichzeitig hat auch
navalny macht und einfluss das zeigt ein
bemerkenswerter film der kein neutrales
porträt von navalny geworden ist sondern
eine chronik der dramatischen monate in
dessen leben ein politthriller aus der
realität unserer zeit den sich kein
autor so hätte ausdenken können barbara
lueg berichtet
nach deutschland zu kommen war nicht
meine absicht ich bin hier gelandet weil
man versucht hat mich umzubringen
alles beginnt mit diesem giftanschlag
navalny schreie seine frau julia die um
sein leben kämpft
und schließlich nach venice genesung in
einem kleinen dorf im schwarzwald hier
trifft regisseur daniel joha mit seiner
kamera auf den großen putin-kritiker
es war eine sehr schrittweise annäherung
bis er uns in sein leben gelassen hat
bis er uns hat filmen lassen das
vertrauen hat sich so ganz langsam
aufgebaut
magst du mich
wochenlang begleitet der regisseur hier
in geheimer mission nicht nur den
regimekritiker navalny sondern auch den
menschen seine frau seine kinder
es sind intime einblicke szenen eine
offenheit die so noch nie zu sehen war
wie etwa die sorgen und gedanken seiner
tochter daria
[Musik]
wenn der eigene vater
angehörende oppositioneller vergiftet
in irgendeinem krater aus landet das war
so real wie sich in einem gremium
das beschauliche dorf im schwarzwald
entpuppt sich während der dreharbeiten
dann auch schon bald als kulisse eines
echten aufklärungs krimis navalny und
sein team machen das killerkommando das
ihn vergiftet haben soll ausfindig unter
falschen namen telefoniert er mit ihnen
vor laufender kamera es ist die
spektakulärste szene im film
warum ging die sache mittlerweile nicht
so daneben
die erst am boden hatten sofort
gehandelt und ihm irgendeinen gegen
mittel verabreicht wäre er nur ein
bisschen länger geflogen wäre wohl alles
anders ausgegangen
[Musik]
er hat die ganze geschichte
ausgeplaudert unglaublich
das war ein moment der so grundlegend so
schockierend so weltumspannend war ich
spreche kein wort russisch aber es war
völlig klar was da gerade im raum
passierte
wo hinterfragt den brillanten
medienstrategie navalny der seine
geschichten am liebsten selbst erzählt
kaum doch woraus große leistung ist die
unmittelbare nähe der zu ihm und seiner
familie fand
zurück in moskau wird navalny umgehend
verhaftet im film hinterlässt er zuvor
eine botschaft meine botschaft
vorher für den fall dass sich umgebracht
werde ist sehr einfach gibt nicht auf
worte die navalny seinen landsleuten zu
ruft aber nun im straflager wohl auch
sich selbst
navalny der film eröffnet morgen das
münchner dok fest und läuft dann ab
donnerstag im kino und hier bei uns
heute hat hanna an diesem dritten
weitere wichtige nachricht auf schloss
meseberg ist heute die bundesregierung
zu einer zweitägigen klausurtagung
zusammengekommen
bestimmendes thema war auch hier der
krieg in der ukraine und seine konkreten
folgen für deutschland zum beispiel in
der sicherheit aber auch in der
wirtschaftspolitik
hier gebe es laut wirtschaftsminister
harbeck große herausforderungen aber
auch antworten wir werden diese zeit
überstehen wir haben die finanziellen
mittel wir haben die politischen
konzepte wir bauen die energieversorgung
um
nach nur kurzer amtszeit ist csu
generalsekretär stephan mayer heute
überraschend zurückgetreten in einer
erklärung nannte er gesundheitliche
gründe allerdings ging er darin auch auf
denen gerade erst bekannt gewordenen
vorwurf ein dass er einen journalisten
bedroht haben soll in einem gespräch mit
einem reporter der bunten habe er zitat
möglicherweise eine wortwahl verwendet
die er rückblickend nicht für angemessen
betrachten würde erklärte meyer der 48
jährige war erst ende februar zum
generalsekretär gekürt worden und sollte
eigentlich den landtagswahlkampf im
kommenden jahr manager
die berliner staatsanwaltschaft hat
ermittlungen gegen ex verkehrsminister
scheuer aufgenommen die im zusammenhang
mit der gescheiterten pkw-maut stehen
konkret geht es um eine mögliche
falschaussage vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestags
scheuer wehrt sich gegen die vorwürfe
und sagte er habe wahrheitsgemäß
ausgesagt die pkw maut war ein
prestige-projekt der csu das 2009 10 vom
europäischen gerichtshof gekippt wurde
trotz der noch ausstehenden
gerichtsentscheidungen hatte scheuer
allerdings bereits verträge mit den
vorgesehenen betreiberfirmen geschlossen
diese verlangen nun vom bund 560
millionen euro schadensersatz an
den weißen marmor stufen des imposanten
gebäudes mit der ebenso imposanten
adresse number one first street
washington dc protestieren sie heute die
einen und die anderen
der grund ist das was aus dem tempel des
rechts dort heraus gedrungen ist ein
leck das es in sich hat aus dem kleinen
eigentlich sehr verschwiegenen zirkel
der obersten richter der usa
da ist jetzt ein entwurf für einen
urteil an die öffentlichkeit gelangt
dass in amerika eine heftige debatte neu
entfacht das recht auf abtreibung ist in
gefahr es sieht so aus als ob die
obersten richter abrücken wollen von
rovers estate diese entscheidung ist
fast fünf jahrzehnte alt und sie spaltet
die usa wie kaum eine andere bis heute
relative
sie sind die vorboten einer unruhigen
zeit in amerika ihre überzeugungen
treiben sie auf die straße bringen sie
gegeneinander auf
sobald das alte urteil abgeschafft ist
müssen wir in den bundesstaaten
sicherstellen dass die gesetze gegen
abtreibung also für das leben
verabschieden
niemals zuvor wurde eine urteilsentwurf
öffentlich selten war eine entscheidung
so scharf formuliert von richter alito
bekannt für seine extreme wort wollen
das urteil von 1973 sei von beginn an
ungeheuerlich falsch gewesen die
begründung außerordentlich schwach die
bundesregelung durch keine
verfassungsrechtliche vorschrift gedeckt
ein beispiel für die ausübung neuer
juristischer macht deshalb sei es nun
zeit die verfassung zu beachten und die
abtreibungsfrage den gewählten
vertretern des volkes zurückzugeben
fünf konservative richter 3 von trump
nominierte wollen die bundesregelung
kippen so ergab eine probeabstimmung
richter alytus scharfe töne hatten schon
in der nacht folgen
demonstranten beider seiten gerieten
aneinander vor dem obersten gerichtshof
wenn das urteil so kommt wird es das
land weiter spalten rund 60 prozent der
bevölkerung sind für eine liberale
regelung
alles für das wir gekämpft haben landet
im müll das ist lächerlich wir haben so
viel erreicht jetzt wird die zeit
zurückgedreht
das werden sie amerika nicht antun wir
sind mehr leute als sie wir werden
kämpfen
es droht ein kulturkampf im land etwa
die hälfte der bundesstaaten hat gesetze
parat nach denen ein
schwangerschaftsabbruch fast komplett
unmöglich in oklahoma beispielsweise
wäre er dann ab der sechsten woche
strafbar also bevor viele frauen
bemerken dass sie schwanger sind
kliniken wie diese würden schließen
frauen in notsituationen müssten in
andere bundesstaaten reisen viele ärmere
hätten gar nicht die mittel dafür auch
unter republikanern gibt es kritik
wenn das urteil in die richtung des
entwurfs geht dann erschüttert dass mein
vertrauen in das gericht
präsident biden hält es für ein
grundsatzurteil dann könnten staaten
auch verhütung verbieten
gleichgeschlechtliche beziehungen
bestrafen und vieles mehr
es sind so viele fundamentale rechte
davon betroffen und ich bin nicht bereit
diese den launen der öffentlichkeit auf
lokaler ebene zu überlassen
es ist war ja in amerika beide seiten
werden alles tun um die wähler im land
in ihr lager zu ziehen
es gebe aber trotz weiter beschäftigen
jetzt aber erstmal zurück nach
deutschland und nochmal hanna seit
wochen wird diskutiert was ein gas
embargo oder ein gas lieferstopp
russlands für deutschland bedeuten würde
jetzt hat die bundesnetzagentur eine
umfrage gestartet um das was wäre wenn
zumindest etwas zu klären und zwar
valerie haller unter unternehmen die
besonders viel gas verbrauchen worum
geht es dabei genau ja es geht darum
einen überblick zu bekommen über den
gasbedarf einzelner branchen und
unternehmen um die auswirkungen eines
russischen lieferstopps einfach besser
einschätzen zu können denn da gehen die
meinungen weit auseinander
fest steht schon mal deutschland hat
eine sehr gas intensive industrie manche
sparten sind besonders abhängig davon
wie zum beispiel die chemiebranche die
viele produkte herstellt die andere
industriezweige wiederum für ihre
produktion brauchen also wenn gas fehlt
hat das weitreichende folgen die
bundesnetzagentur fragt nun bei den 2500
größten gas verbrauchern daten ab um zu
wissen wer im notfall wie viel gas
braucht aktuell gibt es laut netzagentur
genug gas selbst im falle eines akuten
stopps die speicher sind zu 35 prozent
und damit für die jahreszeit ganz gut
gefüllt tendenz steigend nur im winter
würde es eng werden ohne russisches gas
doch selbst dann muss niemand frieren
haushalte werden per gesetz immer zuerst
versorgt gleichzeitig sollen andere gas
quellen erschlossen werden noch dieses
jahr sollen laut wirtschaftsminister
habe zwei schwimmende lng terminals in
betrieb genommen werden so könnte gas
über die deutschen häfen ins europäische
gasnetz eingespeist werden das könnte
wenn auch ein kleiner aber ein weiterer
schritt in richtung unabhängigkeit von
russischem gas werden in den kommenden
jahren sind dann auch stationäre tor
geplant danke valerie nach frankfurt
die lage auf dem deutschen arbeitsmarkt
hat sich im april weiter verbessert und
das trotz des russischen angriffskriegs
in der ukraine
wie die bundesagentur für arbeit in
nürnberg mitteilte waren im april rund
zwei millionen
309.000 menschen arbeitslos 53.000
weniger als im märz die quote sank damit
leicht auf 5 prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahr waren es 462 1000 weniger
arbeitslose die erholung sei auf die
frühjahrsbelebung und die lockerungen
der korona maßnahmen zurückzuführen
nach angaben der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
bko ist mehr als die hälfte der
erwachsenen in europa übergewichtig
dabei sei der anteil bei den männern mit
63 prozent höher als bei den frauen mit
54 prozent
übergewicht und fettleibigkeit hätten
epidemische ausmaße erreicht erklärte
die whu 13 prozent aller todesfälle in
der region seien darauf zurückzuführen
weil das risiko für viele krankheiten
wie krebs oder herz
kreislauferkrankungen erhöht ist
das war unsere welt an diesem dienstag
gleich nach uns jetzt 37 grad hitze hass
gewalt wie auch das zum alltag von
politikern wurde und dann legen wir
ihnen natürlich für 22 uhr 45 den
kollegen markus lanz ans herz sehr
spannende runde unter anderem mit dem
spd-generalsekretär kevin kühnert 22 45
markus lanz und
gegen mitternacht gibt es dann unser
heute-journal update mit nasa spannendes
zdf programm von uns allen hier lange
niemand
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das ist der
satelliten film von heute und er zeigt
uns etliche
wolkenfelder hier in der mitte und auch
nach südost nennen aber im tagesverlauf
haben sich dann schauer und gewitter
entwickeln das sind hier diese kleinen
weißen punkte das sind quellwolken und
teilweise gewitter die sich teilweise
auch nur sehr langsam bewegt haben
deswegen gab es durchaus ordentlich
regen nach norden war es dann eher
trocken diese wolken hier das sind keine
gewitter diesen tarlós wir schauen in
die nacht und da gibt es noch letzte
schauer im südwesten oder auch in den
alpen das lässt nach ansonsten klart es
auf nach nordosten hin und im binnenland
richtung ostsee wird es eisig minus 1
grad ansonsten null grad richtung
norddeutsche tiefebene und 9 grad plus
am im rhein-main-gebiet ja und morgen
dann im tagesverlauf erst einmal so
anscheinend auch im süden und dann
brodelt es erneut wieder schauer und
gewitter und es kann durchaus bei
gewittern bis zu 20 liter auf den
quadratmeter innerhalb einer stunde
geben und das ganze dehnt sich aus bis
etwa zur mitte sonst aber wieder
trockenes wetter die höchsten
temperaturen liegen bei 11 bis 14 grad
richtung nordsee häufig vor allem in der
südhälfte bisher etwa 20 22 grad dann
richtung rhein main gebiet und die
nächsten tage am donnerstag noch einmal
ziemlich durchwachsen im süden 14 bis 20
grad und freitag deutlich ruhiger damit
ein schulamt